I got hello everybody welcome don't
interrupt me when I'm talking
that's sorry we're interrupt me hello
everybody and welcome back to let's play
Orcs Must a - okay that's Tom yeah there
he is
now you may speak all right anyway um
where's the where's the skills bill
spending a spell book that's right
tree here they're all too expensive yeah
not for me but a ballista sucks coin for
just decent if you didn't get it right
paladin Guardians now those are the good
Guardians what was that thing that
enabled you to heal your Guardians I
don't know I think it's an item the
healing trinket healing tree hit there
were Knights there weren't trinkets in
the other one
that weren't knows one of the things
with the ladies you had oh yeah are they
still in this I don't know they haven't
gotten very far either way I'm gonna get
lightning because I want it
and I'm ready
hang on hurry up shut up I'm upgrading
my lightning let's go oh shoot I should
have thought up too late
oh yeah you told me to hurry I
completely forgot you could upgrade
things now yeah yeah okay dwarf go away
yeah no door you suck indeed spike trap
all the way I didn't upgrade my spike
trap oh we got flying things
Oh No wow that's I don't have anything
for flying if your main attack
hey we got archers archers we got well
we got hard two archers ah okay
not I used to spam those once yeah in
the first game oh we got four archers
what a noob strategy well they'll take
care of the flying ones then they won't
take care of
all right go I'm not ready yet
go
oh no I don't have any sticky things
don't care I'll take it I'll just spam
sticky all day long I'll need you to
place them that all sticky all the time
about we gotta go
all right behind the clock here
womp womp womp womp he's only hit -
really what is that lightning
yeah because sworn to hit more than that
guess not that's stupid it hit like 4 or
5 before I don't think so yeah it did
for me at least maybe with some sort of
upgrade or something I don't know but
yeah you might have to upgrade it now I
upgraded it twice right and one was it
could hit another target I thought that
meant they could hit like five instead
of four
and maybe they just have to be more
clumped together - those are the three
Oh watch me do advocate shots oh you're
welcome
got it okay more sticky I guess I should
have closed up that area this is the
only rift right outside
Oh up up up
lightnings pretty good on these guys
planing also used to instant kill
smaller judge whoa hello
ah there's a fork um okay they just got
to be really clumped up now it's a bit
more generous with its range in the
first one like a lot they tightened up a
lot of things yeah I think they're more
focused on skill
skill what's this skill thing
shouting the bagasse
is it is it like these armored guys do
yep like hit their armor I don't under I
just bury
whatever you got no skill man you don't
even know
alright closing it up it'll hurt a lot
no actually I need you to place some
over here shut up
I'll play some where I want to place
them just the optimum for combos shot
drop and where I'll play somewhere you
on s cool
I can't yell if you like I can most of
the other people I play with because I
actually live with you and you can come
over and beat me up
up above up
and out
well actually if they explode do they
hurt their own guys I guess I guess so
yeah cool not bad
get back oh yeah my mana sound totally
the spellcaster of the group is it like
RPG that we could get more help over
time I don't know I didn't see that
option in the upgrades cuz I swear our
health bars and man bars are getting
bigger really I think so I'm going crazy
so am I
pushing him back whoa little guys
BAM oh where do you want the stickies
you can see the cross section right here
just to right there and there warning
yeah that's perfect
well this means we actually have to get
let them get this far for this armor I'm
just gonna block off this side well then
oh yeah that's right that's smart I
don't know enough to block off the whole
thing but uh eventually well somewhere
in the middle of that you do that yeah
so we just have to focus on here
can they walk over that flame trap yeah
okay so just so just go like this okay
all right okay then I will exercise more
on fear
okay let's go you close that up as you
can I'm gonna close up the other side I
sold one of my things
okie dokie that's better go now though
except for the flying ones of course
whatever we're actually using teamwork
that's crazy
yeah I know what a concept just like
when we played portal
at the time you've had to death but
what's that other game that we played
what other game that we're where we
sucked until we did team and until we
actually work together
I don't remember I'm gonna remember you
why are they going that way
I don't know right hand let that one go
Gary's going
that one's going no they changed their
mind oh okay well that's good let's just
delay them a bit more yeah oh they're
going up oh no I didn't realize they
could go up here well why couldn't they
I didn't yeah wow I'm getting hurt
inconceivable
if you could it after this round block
off that issue from oh crap
up above up wrap I'm out of mana where's
the area that you can go recover health
and mana I don't know
it used to be the portal there is none
left by the portals now the entrance
yeah
because this is in the human right I
assume so ow damn it
coming up the center hard push
I got him fish does I need to get some
help back before I die here
others help books not stripper
okay now close up that yeah you don't
have barricades dude no I didn't get it
but okay now we're at it money of slow
now we just got this
easy now they're forced to come inside
yep that's the idea if only there was a
ceiling then we could have a swing shop
- yeah I thought you know sake combos
wait why are they still going okay
they're changing when I go over to the
right because that's where they're all
congregating
how much mana does a lightning cloud
cost
whoa I got sappers coming up towards the
barricades I got them oh shoot I got
don't worry it doesn't cost very much
for me but I think it costs a lot more
yeah just like my whole mana bar yeah I
mean I can do like two of them up above
I got it
they're going up the right side
the upright side
oh shoot
No oh they're kids
oh my beautiful barricades they're five
my man hey I need it they don't need it
oh that's why I don't like barricades
they're too easy to break
oh not normally I guess I should put
more slows on that side just to keep
things getting in there putting the
barricade back here
and let me I'm gonna go see if you can
like get manna back from standing by
here
no don't look like it
just normal regeneration rate up will
you
there we are yeah
okay closed off again good fine maybe
that'll stop him from going that way in
the first place up
oh crap what'd you do up above again
yeah so
on them away
No
I gotta you go
they're coming through left side but
nothing
I'm gonna push them back look at those
comics yeah are you only getting the big
combos somewhat seen 3 and 5 that's
pretty much what I expect without a
swing traffic
you were better at combos and I were
let's go gotta go no time let's go I'm
gonna try to keep each level in one
episode okay
I love flame caps do you they're one of
my favorite caps why I don't know I seem
affected they seem useless
I like seeing things burn yeah you got
problems man
500 lost County
up
got call things out man thought you'd
notice oh of course not
I'm unobservant
we got Flyers on the right
perfect
I forgot that I could try
oh yeah
kill him all in one
and not even a bit of a problem yeah
those are my least favorite enemies
Gold's know that the ones they explode
they ruin all my plans
hmm Mary did you replace this okay good
I want to put sticky traps where you
might put flame traps so I'm trying to
be nice about it oh it's okay
up about half I see
you told me to call him out I was
disagreeing with you I didn't say yeah I
see them
oh god it's hard to tell yeah my sarcasm
so difficult to detect they're flying to
the right was that sarcasm
not funny man
if this was your job would you do it
if this was a job would you do this
what doesn't seem all that dangerous to
me personally so sure
I mean if it's the risk of death we'll
is there you know if you die you
actually be dying oh maybe not that well
you just have to be good at it yeah I
guess where are you gonna get your
practice actually doing it these guys
don't seem all that threatening and if
you let them through all of humanity
dies true it's a bit waiting all right
last one
should be easy hasn't been hard yep
hey we might even get five skulls this
time hey wouldn't that be something if
one of us doesn't die I've got more help
than you do
I never I never hit with lightning
I'm up there yeah
liars up again
I see them out do you surprised we
haven't been getting many odors yeah
even this early in skulls Michael oh
yeah wow that's a big boy
archers
killstreak
almost there
like
where this power leads to just goes back
for doctrines it's usually how it works
yeah Gollum stunned Oh cuz I'm like a
bow you have you hit him in the head it
usually does more damage Thomas I
charmed them
hey stop shooting mine
ah wait that's even unlock queen of the
orcs what oh it's because I'm charming I
guess
okay
so why did she lose own her powers there
we go that's the dance I can't remember
oh I could see your dance yeah like
we're good or something and little
bubbles are a great way now stop playing
this ceiling sure what the hell is that
interesting anyway that's all the time
we got for this episode thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next part
bye bye bye